لن يرضخ مهدي لمعتبره تهديدا علميا من
السلطه لموظفين يتقاضون رواتبهم بالدولار
ولن يتخلى عن نسبه قد تصل الى 25 في المئه
من ضريبه الدخل لدوله سلبت مصاريفها مئات
الالاف من مدخرات عائلته
فموازنه الحكومه ملحقه بقرارات وزير
الماليه تطارد دولارات المواطنين في مصدر
رزقهم
من جديد من خلال انه نقدر نرجع نشتغل نجمع
من جديد
وانا سميته جديد يعني بانه ما يسمى ضريبه
الدخل تحت عنوان الضريبه بيتونياخذوا مره
جديده مصارينا وتعبنا وشقينا اكيد ممكن
نلجا الى الشارع بالتعاون مع جمعيات
المذيعين ورابطه المذيعين وغير من الناس
اللي عم تشتغل بهذا الاطار
اضافه الى امكانيه اللجوء للشارع لوحه
قطاعات اخرى بالاضراب كما فعل اتحاد
نقابات النقل الجوي ما قد يؤثر على حركه
الطيران ويؤدي الى اغلاق المطار
صدرت بالجمله واستنتقادات الموازنه التي
خلت من اي الولود الاصلاحيه لوضع حد
لمزارع
لانه ما كان في اصلاحات ما كان في حوافز
للاستثمارات ما كان في تنميه لهذا
الاقتصاد انما فقط لايجاد موارد لتغذيه
الخزينه من دون اي سياسه الدعم وتحفيز
تحميل عبق ضريبه على اشخاص يمكن معشيتهم
ما بتسمح له الخاصه موظفي القطاع الخاص
اللي هم فعليا هلا نايمين بالحمله
الشطور ممكن لحد الاقتطاع يوصل ل 25%
المفعول الرجعي الي فرضه القرار كمان
واكثر من هيك هو العمل على اساس منصه سيره
فايه اللي هي سعره متحرك وغير ثابت
وبالتالي هذا
بمجمل قرار الوزير هو اا مجمل همم اذا بدك
مجموع من المخالفات
مع الحمله التي شنت وتلويح بعض الشركات
الاجنبيه بنقل افوعها من لبنان قد يتراجع
وزير المال عن القرار لكن تنفيذه يصبح
ساري النهايه الشهر حتى اشعار اخر
قطاع الخاص السلطه بتمويل القطاع العام من
جيوبهم بدلا من تقليص عدد الموظفين
المتضخم والذين زرعتهم الاحزاب السياسيه
في الدوائر الرسميه لممارب انتخابيه غنوه
يتيم العربيه بيروت